Burnie walks away with an arrow win in
New Hampshire Pete Buddha judge and Amy
Klobuchar vie for the most moderate lane
and Joe Biden finally gives up the ghost
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored
by expressvpn you have a right to
privacy so go protected at expressvpn
dot-com slash Ben all righty so last
night New Hampshire primaries and the
big story coming out is Bern baby Bern
Bernie Sanders merges with a very narrow
victory now the question is whether this
is a big win for Bernie or whether it's
kind of a disappointing showing for
Bernie and all of that depends on
whether you think that he should have
consolidated that left leaning lane a
little bit better now here's the reality
most of the Democratic Party has
basically decided that Bernie can't beat
Trump the reason I say that is because
Bernie Sanders won approximately 26% of
the vote last night which means that 74%
so that's who voted in New Hampshire
really didn't like Bernie now does that
mean that he lost of course not this is
sort of like the Republicans in 2016
deciding that most of them thought Trump
couldn't win out that turned out to be
wrong right Bernie could very well win
but suffice it to say the bernie is the
candidate in the race with the highest
level of name recognition other than Joe
Biden and Bernie Sanders is the person
who has the largest organization and
Bernie Sanders is the candidate with the
most money and Bernie Sanders is the
person with the heaviest and most and
most loyal base and all he could drag
out of New Hampshire last night was
about 26% of the vote now contrast that
to New Hampshire Democratic primary
circuit 2016 just four years ago in that
New Hampshire Democratic primary Bernie
Sanders walked away with 60% of the vote
60 against Hillary Clinton who walked
away with 38% of the vote say skunked
her there by 22% he won an outright
majority of the voters in New Hampshire
in 2016 again 60 percent of the vote
well last night he showed up at 26% of
the vote which means that presumably 34
percent of the people who voted for him
well 34 percent of that 60% went to
other candidates which means a lot of
people in the Democratic Party are very
worried about Bernie Sanders as the
actual nominee in terms of delegate
count by the way Peabody Judge is still
ahead of Bernie Sanders because he came
away from Iowa with one more delegate
than Bernie both Bernie and Budi judge
end up winning about nine delegates
budda judge shows strong in New
Hampshire and right now the question is
who
going to fill the moderate lane because
the fact is this if you had to sum up
this campaign so far so to understand
how to sum up this campaign I'm gonna
have to tell a rather growth story about
my throw your old son so the other night
about 2 a.m. my son wakes me up from a
deep sleep shouting daddy daddy run into
his room and he says daddy I need to go
to the bathroom and I take him to the
bathroom or he proceeds to dump half his
body weight in the toilet and we're
sitting there and I keep saying to him
son are you done yet no daddy
are you done no are you done no and
finally about 20 minutes into this he I
finally say to him you're done aren't
you he said yeah I just don't want to go
back to bed ok the reason I bring this
up is because this think of the
Democratic primaries as a toilet bowl I
know it's a stretch but not really think
of the Democratic primaries as a toilet
bowl Joe Biden has been clogging up the
moderate lane and the floater in this
situation would be Bernie Sanders and
unless roto-rooter comes and makes sure
that that moderate lane is cleared up
then Bernie will continue to float at
the top of this waste pool until he is
the nominee right that is the way that
this thing is going to go because the
fact is again that it turns out that the
moderate lane is a lot more crowded
which makes sense because the moderate
lane is usually where the Democratic
Party drops its candidate from right
Hillary's from the moderate lane and
Barack Obama was kind of from the
moderate Lane and John Kerry certainly
was from the more moderate Lane of the
Democratic Party in 2004 and Al Gore was
from the moderate Lane in 2000 Obama
might be the only outlier here and he
had obviously very special circumstances
that attended to him bottom line is this
they're a bunch of candidates who've
decided to be in that moderate Lane and
there's only one candidate with a
significant base inside the progressive
Lane and that is Bernie Sanders so here
are the actual results by vote count
last night Bernie Sanders won about
seventy five thousand four hundred bucks
which by the way isn't it amazing than
in this country of three hundred thirty
million people effectively speaking
about a hundred thousand voters really
like 125 thousand voters total in Iowa
New Hampshire basically decide who the
nominees in the major parties are gonna
be because one candidate walks away from
Iowa or New Hampshire with both
victories very difficult to stop him
even if they walk away with one victory
it's usually somebody who won one of
those states winds up being the nominee
Bernie Sanders won about seventy five
thousand votes last night people who
judge won about seventy two thousand
votes last night Amy Klobuchar one of
fifty-eight thousand votes last night
and Joe Biden who will not drop out of
this race I mean if you were if you
really wanted to save the Democratic
Party Joe Biden needs to get out and he
needs to get out right now Joe Biden won
eight point four percent of the vote
a brutal showing finishing fifth in New
Hampshire a state that he had competed
in right Michael Bloomberg didn't
compete in the states he can't really
talk about how Bloomberg did in that
state even though President Trump tried
to suggest that that that somehow this
is a failure last night for Michael
Bloomberg who didn't run in the state
bottom line is it was a failure for Joe
Biden who won 24,000 votes in the state
less than Elizabeth Warren's also dismal
showing of 27,000 votes in the state
Elizabeth Warren by the way is somebody
who's supposed to be highly competitive
in the state at borders New Hampshire
just like Vermont borders New Hampshire
Bernie walks away with it Elizabeth
Warren completely collapses just an
awful showing she's not dropping out
either so you have too many candidates
who are sticking around and not enough
candidates who are dropping out which is
going to lead to the most consolidated
Ken and Emily Bernie being the person
with the with the most momentum moving
forward there also happens to be a real
stubborn effect for voters when they
look at the quote unquote establishment
Democratic Party and it's not quite the
same as it was for Republicans in 2016
generally Democrats are happier with
their party than republicans are with
their party so when Trump ran against
the Republican Party in 2016
had a lot to run on Democrats tend to be
a little happier internally with their
party but Sanders does have the ability
to run against the media and you're
seeing that have an impact to take for
example one New Hampshire woman she said
she told MSNBC the reason I'm voting for
Bernie is because you guys keep telling
me not to vote for Bernie I want to say
the reason I went for Bernie is because
of MSNBC and go on
I think it is completely cynical to say
that he's lost 50% of his vote from the
last time when there were two candidates
the stop Bernice's and cynicism that I
heard from a number of people i watch
NBC MSNBC constantly so I heard that
from a number of commentators and so
that just it made me angry enough I said
okay Bernie's got my vote okay I'm sure
there are some members of the Democratic
Party who feel the same way which is
that the stop Bernie campaign from the
establishment Democratic Party actually
is leading them to vote more likely for
Bernie Sanders we'll get to more of the
election analysis from last night in New
Hampshire because there were some good
news for the Democrats and there's some
bad news for the Democrats and then
there's some very bad news for the
Democrats so we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that Valentine's Day quickly
approaches and gentlemen have you done
your duty if you have not if you've not
gone out and gotten your lady some
flowers and I mean like really nice
flowers you're doing it wrong there is
no time left this is the last minute
right now 1-800 flowers has amazing
offers on beautiful Valentine's Day
bouquets and arrangements there are
still time to have your bouquet
delivered on Valentine's Day but you've
got to get moving with an amazing
selection of sweets treats and bouquets
1-800 flowers has everything you need
for Valentine's and she will never guess
how great of a Lampman
last-minute deal you scored because all
she knows is that the flowers are
showing up right now time is running out
to lock in these Valentine's Day offers
so order today it's only good while
supplies last after you've chosen your
gorgeous bouquet or arrangement simply
pick your delivery date let 1-800
flowers handle the rest the flowers are
absolutely beautiful they last a really
long time unlike the stuff you get from
the grocery store I mean they they come
beautifully packaged you can get
packages with it with a beautiful vase I
mean like it really is fantastic every
time I go out of town I order my wife
1-800 flowers because I'm just that kind
of husband you could be - all you have
to do is go to 1-800 flowers calm toward
a beautiful vibrant Valentine bouquets
go to 1-800 flowers calm Shapiro
Valentine's Day is indeed here so
ordered today say the 1-800 flowers calm
/ Shapiro okay so there are some good
news for the Democrats and there's some
bad news for Democrats and then there
are some very bad news for Democrats the
good news for Democrats is that turnout
last night overall for the Democrats was
higher than it was in 2008 okay well
that is kind of keeping up with the
population was higher than it was in
2016 that is good news for Democrats
because one of the narratives coming out
of Iowa is that people when we're not
showing up in massive number
in order to vote in Iowa which kind of
gave the lie to the idea that there was
a tremendous voter enthusiasm to get rid
of President Trump so last night about
two hundred eighty eight thousand voters
on the Democratic side showed up to vote
in New Hampshire that was compared to
about two hundred ninety two thousand
expected about two hundred eighty four
thousand showed up in two thousand eight
in 2016 the number was something like
two hundred fifty six thousand so it was
a slight increase it consummate with the
population growth in the state of New
Hampshire so that is good news for the
Democrats in New Hampshire is that
people apparently were interested in
voting now there are some very bad news
for the Democrats in New Hampshire and
that is the people who showed up to vote
and this was reflected in Bernie's
results again he went from sixty percent
in 2016 all the way down to twenty six
percent in 2020 this was largely because
the increase in voter turnout was among
older people it was not among younger
people so Bernie is counting on this
vast upsurge in youth voting in order to
drive him to victory in a 2020 general
election we have not seen any evidence
of that in Iowa we have seen no evidence
of that in New Hampshire either in fact
according to Steve Kornacki over at
MSNBC early New Hampshire exit polls
showed only eleven percent of New
Hampshire voters were seventeen to
twenty nine which was down from 19
percent in 2016 that that is a
significant significant drop in the
youth vote in New Hampshire them down 20
percent from 2016 and as usual people
over 65 were turning out the most more
than that CNN's David Chalian
reported that only 12 percent of exit
voters said they were first-time voters
which was actually lower than 2016 so
everybody who voted in 2016
showed up to vote again but very few
people showed up additionally so all the
people that Bernie is counting on namely
voters who didn't vote last time and
young people those people didn't
actually show up to vote in New
Hampshire which is why Bernie who is
very popular in New Hampshire as
evidenced by again the fact he won six
out of ten Democratic voters in 2016 and
that is why he squeaks out a very narrow
victory and there are headlines today
that Bernie underperformed which is true
Bernie did underperform now this is
alleviated by the fact that the other
big frontrunner dramatically
underperformed but Bernie went out
yesterday and he had to fire up the base
and he says this is the beginning of the
end for Trump which is a lot of wishful
thinking for Bernie Sanders by the way
worth noting Donald Trump ran
opposed in New Hampshire normally when
you are an incumbent he didn't run
unopposed bill weld ran whatever but
when you are when you are an incumbent
president typically not that many people
show up to vote for you in the primary
because why do you bother
it's like voting for the sky to be blue
rather the incumbent president is going
to be the person who comes out of the
New Hampshire primary no matter what
because there's literally no serious
opposition to President Trump
inside the Republican Party how many
people showed up to vote for Trump just
because his name was on the ballot last
night that 118 thousand Republicans
showed up in New Hampshire and voted
Trump hate to put that by way of
contrast when Barack Obama was running
for reelection in 2012 in New Hampshire
suddenly 55,000 Democrats showed up to
vote for him that means that Donald
Trump blew out whatever record New
Hampshire had for an incumbent president
running in the New Hampshire primaries
what does that mean it means that the it
means that the enthusiasm for Trump is
extraordinarily high it also means the
Bernie Sanders right he won what did I
say 75,000 votes something that is 75 75
thousand four hundred I don 'old Trump
150 thousand more votes then Bernie
Sanders did right and again Bernie was
running in a crowded field but the fact
that that many people showed up just to
vote for Donald Trump in an uncontested
election demonstrate that the enthusiasm
is on Trump sight nonetheless Bernie was
out there at his rally talking about how
this is the beginning of Donald Trump
unbelievable let me say tonight that
this victory here is the beginning of
the end for Donald Trump
with victories behind us popular vote in
Iowa and the victory here tonight we're
going to Nevada we're going to South
Carolina we're going to win those
okay now there's a good shot that he
does win Nevada and there's a fairly
good shot that he wins South Carolina as
we'll get to in a moment
none of these Democrats are getting out
of the race which means that you've got
a 2016 problem for the diamond for the
Democrats in 2016
basically Rubio wouldn't get out Cruz
wouldn't get out there Kasich wouldn't
get out there was no consolidation of
the anti-trump lane and so Trump just
kept winning 35% of the vote and then
third it started off at like 25 then 30
then 35 is that as the time went on and
by the end who is winning you know 50
percent of the vote in some of these
states it could be exactly the same
thing for Bernie so as I said there's
good news for Democrats that is the
overall turnout in New Hampshire of
slightly up there's bad news for
Democrats which is that that turnout was
coming from the not Bernie Sanders camp
which is why it was very narrow victory
for Bernie Sanders and then there is the
very bad news for Bernie Sanders for the
Democratic Party that is that Bernie
Sanders is likely to be the nominee and
as we'll explore momentarily this is
very very bad for the Democratic Party I
mean at least if you have to forecast
this stuff and we do right I mean that's
our job here is to try and think through
the ramifications of decisions that are
being made today for tomorrow now we
could be wrong listen the economy could
collapse suddenly could have a communist
president like Bernie Sanders could
happen could happen but if you're a
Democrat you woke up this morning and
you should be disquieted unless you are
one of the 25% of voters in the
Democratic Party who believe that an
open out-and-out socialist who's calling
for nationalization of every major
industry in his mid 30s and has never
appeared ated those views that that guy
is a 78 year old an octogenarian
communist who has never done a useful
thing in his entire life that that guy
is destined to be President of the
United States despite a blooming
capitalist economy in the United States
well unless you're one of those 25%
you've got to feel a little
uncomfortable today we'll talk about
that in just one second first let's talk
about the reality of life and one of
those realities is the fact that you
know there is crime in your neighborhood
in my neighborhood there certainly is in
Los Angeles we've seen an increase in in
petty crime we've seen Breaking and
Entering happening in particularly the
neighborhood where I live because the
mayor of LA is garbage at his job and so
does the City Council and so what that
means that crime rates have been going
up well aside from the fact that my
family in particular has safety risks
because of what I do for a living also
that just basic level of crime that has
been increasing in a lot of major cities
that those basic levels of crime and the
petty crime the Breaking and Entering
that means the
you really should have some protective
devices on your property what I mean by
that is you should have written out a
spring loaded shotgun I mean you should
be monitoring a property you should be
able to know what is happening on your
property at all times you should know
when somebody rings the doorbell to drop
off a package because sometimes people
who are looking to break and enter they
ring the doorbell specifically so that
they can tell that you're not home and
then they will go into your house
well ring allows you to pick up from
anywhere tell who is at your front door
call the cops make sure that your
property is safe and right now as a
subscriber you have a special offer on a
ring welcome kit available at ring.com
/ban my property is covered with ring
devices because I want to make sure that
my property and my kids specifically are
safe at all times the kit from ring
includes a video doorbell and a chime
Pro which is just what you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home today go to ring comm /ban that's
ring comm / find if I trust ring to
protect my family you can sure as hell
bet that ring can protect your family as
well I am paranoid about this stuff
that's why I have ring go to ring.com /
Ben that is ringing calm / Ben hey so as
I say the good news turnout up slightly
in New Hampshire bad news it's all
coming from old people really bad news
Bernie Sanders appears to be the person
who is cruising toward the nomination
Democratic Representative Tim Ryan from
Ohio who early on had declared a
presidential run he said yesterday um
guys we're gonna lose 48 states I mean a
bernie is the nominee we're just gonna
get walloped which by the way would be
an unbelievable result right president
Trump to go from winning a minority of
the vote of the popular vote to winning
48 states that I think it's an
exaggeration like Massachusetts in
California are never voting Trump in
Massachusetts California Vermont like
there certainly there are certain states
that just are never gonna go for it New
York these are these are states that are
like for the days of 48 states are over
but you could easily see president from
winning at least 40 states because there
are a number of states New Hampshire is
one of them he lost very narrowly to
Hillary Clinton you could see if Bernie
Sanders is the nominee a bunch of states
that were right on the cusp Minnesota
was another one of them you can see
those states move into Trump's Lane here
is Tim Ryan absolutely panicking
yesterday over the prospects of Bernie
Sanders is the nominee
I personally am very very concerned
about some of the folks who are running
I think you know if we run under a
Democratic Socialist banner in 50 states
I think we lose the industrial Midwest I
think we lose four
eight states I think we lose
working-class Union voters who have
negotiated their private health care and
want to keep it and they don't want to
be forced into a public health care
system you lose those voters these
worries are not idle is there bunch of
people in the burning camp say no no no
this is an exaggeration of the situation
okay let's take a look at some of the
exit polls last night first of all one
of the big wraps on Trump is that he's
gonna do really poorly with women right
though that with women in particular
that suburban women are going to turn
away from Trump that's true if he was
running against a democratic moderate
who does not alienate women let's take a
look at the exit polls in New Hampshire
last night here the exit polls in New
Hampshire among males so 57% of the vote
in New Hampshire among Democrats
according to the NBC News exit poll was
female hey according to those polls
Bernie Sanders didn't come in first with
women he didn't come in second with
women he came in third with women Amy
Klobuchar came in first with 25% p blue
judge came in second with 23% and Bernie
Sanders came in third with 22% among men
Bernie Sanders came in first by a wide
margin with 31% Hebrew to judge came in
second with 20% and Amy Klobuchar came
in third with 16% which is to say that
there was a nine-point gap between men
and women with regard to Bernie Sanders
mirroring very much the gender gap that
exists for president Trump so if you are
putting women in the position of having
to choose suburban women in the position
of having to choose between their job or
their husband's job and their income and
their health plan and Bernie socialism
they're gonna hold their nose many of
them in vote for Trump they really are
and then there's another New Hampshire
Democratic primary exit poll analysis
that came out from the Washington Post
and it showed who is winning each group
so let's look at the groups that Bernie
Sanders did it really well with so he
did well with people aged 18 to 29
as we mentioned those people did not
show up to vote their turnout in 2020
was down 20 percent from 2016 which is
pretty unbelievable in a competitive
primary also the the he won with people
who consider themselves very liberal the
percentage of the American population
that considers itself very liberal is
low but I was gonna vote Democrat anyway
he led among people whose top issue was
income inequality and among people
who never attend a religious service
which is not people in the Midwest
generally religious observance is much
higher in the Midwest than it is on the
coasts he won with men but that is Trump
stronghold he is not going to
breakthrough with Trump and men he is
not Trump just has a massive gender gap
Trump is much more popular with men
generally than Bernie Sanders he did
well with Union households but as it
comes out that Bernie Sanders wants to
get rid of the Cadillac plans a
negotiated by many unions as Tim Ryan
points out right there then a lot of
unions are gonna turn against them as
well see they're already doing this in
Nevada and needs it well with people
whose income was less than $50,000 which
sounds great except for the fact that
that also happens to be a voter group
that tends to turn out less than its
general percentage of the population so
in other words Bernie did really well
among the groups that are a shrinking
share of the American electorate right
he did really well among the groups that
don't show up to vote which is a
disaster
for Democrats now you look at Amy
Klobuchar right who's the person if
Democrats were smart they would mobilize
behind Amy Klobuchar I've been saying
this for at least a week I've actually
been saying this for long in them and
saying for several months that it's
bewildered to me why Amy Klobuchar
doesn't have a higher level of support
she did really well last night
Amy Klobuchar scored about 20% in New
Hampshire blowing out both Joe Biden and
Elizabeth Warren look at her crowd among
people who attend religious services
weekly she won by 12 those are the
people that the Democrats need to win
they need to not alienate the religious
voters who still represent a majority of
voters in this country now the Democrats
have a bit of a conflict which is that
the plurality and maybe majority of
voters in the Democratic electorate are
of no religious affiliation are not
religious but in the country the country
is so overall a religious country Amy
Klobuchar one those voters right that's
a big share that you need to win and she
won among voters who are age 65 and
older who are the people who she needs
to cut into if she hopes to sing Trump
those are the people that Bernie did
worst with so this is the P Buddha judge
by the way one with people whose top
issue was climate change which by a Pew
poll yesterday is the second to last
issue that Americans care about that
means that if Democrats were smart they
would mobilize behind Amy Klobuchar but
the problem is of course that the
Democratic middle lane has been clogged
up by Biden and that was the other big
story last night
so there's a question as to where the
big story was Bernie winning which again
sort of foreseen or whether it was
Bernie underperforming which I tend to
think was a bigger story because it does
mean that this is still a competitive
primary season we've only Don two states
at this point we haven't hit Super
Tuesday yet as we'll see Michael
Bloomberg is ramping up the spending he
continues to spend literally hundreds of
millions of dollars on advertising in
states that have not been pulled yet we
have no idea how that is charting but
the really big story last night is that
Joe Biden continues to just collapse I
mean Joe Biden last night did not only
leave the state of New Hampshire early
for seeing loss there he didn't even
travel to Nevada now I've been saying
for a while if he loses in Iowa New
Hampshire and Nevada he's toast because
there's no way to recover from that and
win South Carolina and then start
sweeping on Super Tuesday and you've
been seeing his poll numbers in South
Carolina collapse it's not as though his
poll numbers in South Carolina are
bulletproof they absolutely are not the
latest polling data from South Carolina
is not beneficial to to Joe Biden
particularly the the post Courier for
example did a poll at the end of January
and it showed that Biden was only up 25
2004 Bernie Sanders of Tom Styer who's
been spending a fortune in South
Carolina scoring at 18 percent of the
vote in South Carolina
now stires gonna stay in until South
Carolina there was some talk maybe he'll
drop out he's not going to he spent all
of his money in South Carolina
why exactly what he dropped out in New
Hampshire there's one good poll that has
come out in the last few days about a
week and a half ago actually from East
Carolina University but that came out
again before the Iowa caucuses and that
showed Biden up 37 to 19 over style with
Sanders all the way down at 14 but it is
unlikely that that is going to be the
case after Bernie wins a couple of
primaries and presumably after humans
Nevada as well okay in just a second
we're gonna get to the epic collapse of
Joe Biden because it is amazing so he
needs to drop out cuz he's just clogging
up that middle lane right he's clogging
up that pipe roto-rooter needs to come
and blow that thing out because right
now Bernie's just gonna float to victory
with 25 26 percent of the vote as long
as Joe Biden is in there sucking up time
sucking up energy preventing the
consolidation that middle lane we get
some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about sleep quality so
as you know this mind right here this is
a finely tuned Ferrari it's just running
running and running and it's like LeMans
I mean just runs 24 hours a day except
when I got on that helix sleep mattress
because this thing is so calm
furball and it puts me to sleep right
away now I am NOT a great sleeper when I
was at Harvard Law School
I remember that pretty much every Friday
night I have some form of insomnia part
of that is because Friday nights at
Harvard what the hell's going on
especially on Shabbat but beyond that I
was sleeping on like this old wumpy
mattress at Harvard well now I have a
beautiful wonderful mattress created
just for me
by helix-loop-helix sleep has a quiz it
takes just 2 minutes to complete and
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper or a
hot sleeper whether you like a pleasure
from bed with helix there's no more
confusing and no more confusion and no
more compromising all you have to do is
go to helix sleep calm slash Ben take
their 2 minutes sleep quiz that they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they've got a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
indeed love it
because it's made for you what's not to
love it's like you ordered a custom ice
cream sundae and it comes what's not to
like you made it for you I mean it's a
helix sleep mattress made for you so
good I got one for my sister for her
wedding helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 200 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash pen that's helix
sleep comm / ben if i can sleep on a
helix with mattress anyone can because
again it's made just for me and it is
supremely comfortable helix sleep comm /
ben and get up to $200 off check that
out right now okay so the big story of
the night other than bernie sanders
continuing to sort of float along at 25
26 percent of the vote is the epic
collapse of joe biden there was a third
big story - which is the epic collapse
of elizabeth warren but that's more
hilarious than anything else
watching watching that pathological liar
i'm just fall apart like a mudslide in
the Hollywood Hills has been
extraordinarily entertaining so let me
just take a moment and pay tribute to
the worst campaign of them all
so elizabeth warren is now in full-on
morning mode and it is delicious
so last night she said she's not gonna
drop out because of course she can't
drop out if she drops out then it
demonstrates that her campaign has been
one of the biggest failures in recent
memory
since Pamela Harris I mean this was like
a massive failure as of October she was
the presumptive nominee she was leading
in New Hampshire she was leading in Iowa
she was she was picking up ground in
places like South Carolina and then she
presented her Medicare for all plans she
tried to put flesh on the bones of
Bernie Sanders is garbage plan and she
completely fell apart just imploded okay
so last night she tweeted
that a a analyst a girl a 19 year old
woman who went to was going to college
and she came up to Elizabeth Warren
complaining that she had a lot of
students that she said I have six
dollars in my bank accounts and I'm
giving three dollars of it to you and
Elizabeth Warren tweeted that out as
though this was a mark of her vision um
that seems first of all pretty
regressive is it not right I mean like
the woman has six dollars to her name
and you're taking three of them for your
garbage campaign that is gonna blow it
on ads that have no impact this person
is just terrible she had terrible person
so last night she she announced that she
was staying in in the race for no
apparent reason because she's got no
shot at the nomination I mean Bernie is
consolidating and she's in Bernie's Lane
he's picked up all his support from her
here is Elizabeth Warren being awful at
this you know me
did the speech and then afterwards did a
selfie line and we were there for over
an hour people are coming through and
they're saying thank you or and they're
giving hugs and talking about what's
important to them him young woman came
up by herself
and she said I'm a broke college student
with a lot of student loan debt and she
said I checked and I have six dollars in
the bank so I just gave three dollars to
keep you in this fight that's what we
gotta do we have to take money from
people who can't afford it that's what
we got to do in fact Elizabeth Warren
and smacked her across the face and said
what is your other three dollars did you
bring your other three dollars lady
don't you want to win don't you want my
campaign to be successful if you were
really willing to fight you would give
me the other three dollars in your bank
account and don't worry I'll alleviate
all student loan debt at the end
in fact buns just rack up another 20
grand in student loan debt you can match
yourself out right here on this campaign
and don't worry a little bit later I
will relieve all student loan debt you
know if you have to falsify the the
documents a little bit just to give me
some money and funnel it to me and take
it out of student loan debt than just
gonna hand it to me
that's totally but what a terrible human
being I mean seriously if somebody came
up to me at an event and they were like
I have six dollars to my name and I want
you to have five of those dollars I'd be
like no here is a 20 go get yourself a
nice meal like seriously it's this bird
said who is this that's insane
but that's elizabeth warren's campaign
from top to bottom completely ridiculous
completely insane completely out of
touch with with regular Americans even
while pretending to represent regular
Americans ladies been teaching at
Harvard Law for twenty years I mean
she's not been in touch with regular
Americans for several decades at this
point and by regular Americans I mean
people who don't have tons of money in
their bank account it's just it's crazy
her new pitch by the way is that people
are being mean to each other and mean to
her that's her new pitch so she got
skunked last night I mean just destroyed
she won nine point six percent of the
vote in a state neighboring her own she
won a grand total of eleven thousand
votes last night just a brutal brutal
showing okay and Elizabeth Warren then
gets up in Manchester New Hampshire says
yeah we were bad but people keep
fragmenting this party and that's
terrible
no one has fragmented this party more
than Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren
has been an attack dog against virtually
everybody else to get on that stage and
she's she's awful and pretty soon those
sweaters that the good news is ladies if
you're looking for an Taylor Loft
multicolored sweaters those will be on
half price within a matter of about
three weeks because Elizabeth Warren's
demand for them will have dropped
ridiculously ridiculously dramatically
so here's Elizabeth Warren saying
everyone is mean and mean to me and
everybody's mean and they need to stop
being mean the fight between factions in
our party has taken a sharp turn in
recent weeks with ads mocking other
candidates and with supporters of some
candidates shouting curses at other
Democratic candidates these harsh
tactics might work if you are willing to
burn down the rest of the party in order
to be the last man standing we're going
to need a huge turnout within our party
and to get that turnout we will need a
nominee that the broadest coalition of
our party feels like they can get behind
yeah which is not you which is not you
by the way
her actual final showing I was reading
with like thirty nine percent of the
vote in their actual showings about
twenty seven thousand votes last night
she end up 19.2 percent of the vote just
a horrible horrible showing for
Elizabeth Warren I love that she's like
we're splitting the party we're
splitting the party and that's why I'm
staying in to split the party some more
okay but she wasn't even the biggest
collapse last night obviously the
biggest collapse last night was Joe
Biden he was the front-runner in every
poll almost Wired wire in Iowa
in New Hampshire had been showing a
close second to Bernie Sanders and then
no one showed up to vote for him no one
won CNN correspondent was going around
talking to New Hampshire voters and said
I could not find anyone here who
supports Biden I asked Jill and Jill was
like maybe I kind of like Bernie here's
the CNN correspondent explaining that no
single human being could be found in the
state of New Hampshire who liked Joe
Biden most surprising here is that of
all the voters I've talked to and we're
talking probably upwards of a hundred
right now not a single one saying they
support Joe Biden ouch ouch CNN's John
King says the same thing he says the big
headline tonight
rotten performance by Biden this is two
straight states where he has just so
apparently his fourth fifth third first
plan is going perfectly remember they
had this with Rubio Rubio was gonna
finish third in Iowa then who's gonna
finish second in New Hampshire and then
he's gonna get and then he was gonna
finish first in South Carolina and
Nevada well yeah that that didn't
materialize it turns out that you can
not continue losing and then consider
that you are a winner this is why this
quixotic quest by Elizabeth Warren to
continue running his bizarre by the way
if she got out a lot of that vote would
move over to Bernie Sanders so that is
worth noting at this point but Biden is
sucking up a lot of time a sucking up a
lot of money and sucking up a lot of
votes right I mean imagine those eight
percent go to Amy Klobuchar or derpy
Buddha judge or imagine that Klobuchar
and Buddha judge and Biden or one
candidate which of course is not true
but if that were the case that would be
well over 50% of the vote in New
Hampshire well over 50% of the vote in
Iowa in any case the the CNN's John King
was saying listen Joe Biden is just a
dead man walking at this point which is
obviously true former vice president
states first know we're second way up
there I'll take a look at the size of
that in a minute but again this is I'm
almost I almost don't want to do it
because it's it feels mean to do it
we're talking about a very tiny place up
here for vote two I've got to do I in
the town so it feels almost mean to do
it
but that just tells you that again
you're not first you're not second
you're not third in any places
significance on the map that is the
definition of a very bad night okay a
horrible night for Joe Biden Chris
Matthews is like wait you're going
didn't even stick around New Hampshire
just took off you went to China
hopefully not with hunter to pick up
money but you just kind of left
I rely in here
come here they show all rumpled thinking
about the fact that Bernie Sanders gave
me the nominee of our party
I mean I'm old enough to remember when
socialism was kind of bad it is it is an
amazing statement by the way about your
network when Chris Matthews is the most
reasonable person on your network which
is what he is becoming in the face of
people like Chris Hayes it's it's wild
here's chris matthews last night on
where's Joe going and maybe doesn't even
know which direction is up anymore what
the hell is going on going to China
I need Saskatchewan why why are you
going there I don't know it's like
Johnny Appleseed just dropping bad
campaigns in his wake here we go go
Biden is now going to basically the
island off of China you know where he
thinks he can hold on
against the mainland he's like it's like
Taiwan that's what he's talking about
there
Taiwan he's like he's like Chiang
kai-shek leaving China trying to get
away from the Communists and now he
can't even find a respite she's running
away running away but I mean that is
accurate we'll get to Joe Biden's
reaction to all of this last night
because Joe Biden is basically in full
panic mode and honestly if Joe Biden
were as much of a patriot for the
Democratic Party as he says he is he
would get out right now
because dude has he's done he's toast
put him in shut the shut the fridge this
night is over for Joe Biden okay it is
it is done it is done we're gonna get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about a great meaningful gift
that you can get for Valentine's Day or
for Mother's Day or for any birthday or
for like just you should get this gift
because it is beautiful here's what you
should do you should head over to paint
your life calm why what is great over
pain your life here's what they do you
send them a picture and then they will
create an original painting of you or
your kids or your family or a special
place or a cherished pet at a price you
can afford and it's beautiful right now
over my mantel I have hanging a picture
of me and my wife and my two kids soon
to be three and it's in when-whenever
third kit I will go back to paint your
life from will take a new picture of
that will have them paint it and the way
that it works that you go to paint your
life you submit your photo and then you
can pick from a variety of artists find
a style that you like and an artist that
you like and then they will send you
pictures along the way and you can keep
redoing it until you get what you like
it is a work of art that is important to
your family for a really affordable
affordable price right now as a limited
time off you get 30% off your painting
and paint your life that's right 30% off
and free shipping to get this special
offer text the word Ben it's a 64,000
that is been to 64,000 again yet 30% off
your painting and it is just an amazing
amazing gift
I mean imagine that you go to your
parents house and you got them a
portrait of them for their anniversary
and it didn't cost you a fortune
they don't have to know that and you
give that I mean just a great great gift
text Ben it's a 64,000 that is my name
Ben - 64,000 get 30% off your painting
at paint your life calm again that's
paint your life calm there's no risk by
the way if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded it's an
amazing really special gift text Ben -
64,000 also last week I told you all
about this amazing podcast the cold war
what we saw over the weekend this
podcast went to number one in history
podcast number five on all of Apple so
now you know I'm not the only one buddy
I'm not the only person saying it this
podcast is really phenomenal the story
is well told the setting is brilliantly
descriptive you get a sense of what it
was like to live through major events
like the Berlin Airlift the Korean War
the Cuban Missile Crisis the space race
these milestones are tied together to
give you a sense of the big picture the
apocalypse that never happened they've
ordered at least two episodes of this 12
part series I was listening to a Welles
running it the other day it really is
fantastic the podcast emphasizes the
struggle between freedom and tyranny
between capitalism and communism the
struggle for civilization itself head on
over to daily wire.com slash Cold War
start listening to this incredibly
important story that is really superb
Lee told that is daily wire.com slash
Cold War also gang if you haven't
noticed already 20/20 is a crazy news
filled year the election race is just
getting started we know that you need to
know everything from debate and primary
updates to the latest nonsense from the
Democratic candidates the best way to
stay informed become a daily wire member
get comprehensive news and opinion from
us on demand so we are giving you 20%
off all memberships the promotion is
ending like super soon get 20% off all
memberships when you use promo code GW
2020 members get our articles had free
access to all of our live broadcast and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show select bonus content
access to the mailbag and now my
election insight op-eds plus our new
i'll access to your gets you into live
online Q&A discussions with me Andrew
Klavan Matt Walsh Michael moles plus our
sites writers and special guests let us
answer your questions help you stay one
step ahead of left if you haven't
already download The Daily wear app so
you get push notifications for breaking
news and special coverage it's a really
awesome feature again this will be
ending very soon do not wait or you will
miss out that is promo code
w20 twenty four twenty percent off so
joined today stay in a stay informed on
all things 2020 related you're listening
to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
America
[Music]
so Joe Biden last night reacting to his
devastating destruction in New Hampshire
I mean just a decimation of his campaign
finishing fifth in New Hampshire this is
the former vice president of the United
States who finished fifth - an
octogenarian communist a mayor of a town
of like five people a senator from
Minnesota who until five minutes ago had
no public attention and Elizabeth Warren
who has absolutely collapsed and he
finished fifth a devastating showing no
wonder Joe Biden is walking around
getting increasingly angry yesterday he
got angry at a reporter asking him
questions here's what that sounded like
not at all not at all they know we've
worked our heart here we're continuing
with it and this is it I'm not concerned
about it all my face okay buddy don't
put that in my I mean he's getting
increasingly increasingly angry and
you've seen this in many of his rallies
like he's getting more and more
irritated by this whole thing and why
wouldn't he be I mean he thought that he
was gonna cruise to the nomination here
and instead he is Joe exclamation point
in the same way that it was Jeb
exclamation point in 2016 last night he
he sounded like honestly he sounded like
a desperate desperate man he was on
stage in South Carolina he sort of he
sort of did his rally in New Hampshire
from South Carolina because he is
desperately attempting to hold what he
perceives to be a firewall in South
Carolina say did this rally and there he
was saying it's it ain't over man it
ain't over you can't shut this bar I got
one more drink left you can't shut this
bar is not over man no no I need one
more bet one more bet on this relay
table I know I've maxed out but I need
one more bet guys it's not over it's not
it's over Joe it's over just call it
this thing's over we just heard from the
first two of 50 states - not all the
nation not half the nation not a quarter
of the nation not 10% too - all right
come from that's the opening bell not
the closing bell
so in here all these pundits and experts
cable TV talkers talked about the race
tell them it ain't over man we're just
game over man game over nuke it from
orbit this thing is toast shut it down
because again here's the reality if you
had said to anybody Bernie that Bernie
is gonna win the first two states and
probably Nevada is gonna win the first
three and by the time you get to South
Carolina Joe Biden with 1-0 victories
and not finish presumably I don't think
he's gonna finish in the top three in
Nevada I think he's gonna get blown out
Nevada I think that I think Bernie
Sanders is gonna win Nevada and I think
that Peabody jej or Amy Klobuchar will
finish second or third in Nevada I would
not be surprised if Joe Biden finishes
fourth or fifth in Nevada I mean that is
why he's flying to South Carolina
presumably if he thought he's gonna win
in Nevada or he has shot at Nevada why
wouldn't he before flying to Nevada I
mean that's the next place right but
he's he's actually backing up all the
way till the end of February because the
election in South Carolina doesn't
happen until I believe February 28th or
Febuary 29th or something so this is
really really bad showing Jimmy Fallon
last night calling this thing he says
listen Biden merch it's about to get a
lot cheaper so if you've been waiting
for that Biden merchant now would be
your time to stock up the New Hampshire
primary was held today in good news if
anyone's in the market for some Joe
Biden campaign merchandise I think it's
about to get a whole lot cheaper based
on a lot of polls Joe Biden was on track
to finish the night and fourth or fifth
place I'm not saying Biden's in trouble
but the coronavirus is pulling ahead of
him
but this is true today Biden actually
left New Hampshire early to start
campaigning in South Carolina and since
it was Joe Biden he didn't really leave
early as much as wander off he's done
he's done Van Jones over on CNN was
wildly depressed last night which is
funny because Van Jones is a person who
basically was ousted from the Obama
administration for being too far left so
you'd imagine the ease in the Bernie
camp last night but here's the thing
about Van Jones at least dudes honest I
mean I know Van Jones a little bit I
really like Van Jones as human being Van
Jones last night he was like I'm
depressed we're all depressed I think
we're all gonna hang ourselves this is
awful
correct Van Jones correct here it is I
think people are depressed you know I
think people are sad
I think people can't figure out which of
these people are supposed to vote for
and I think people are waiting to come
out to vote against Donald Trump I do
think that this is an aberration we're
in this weird thing where to your point
earlier people were coming out to vote
on a Wednesday for an off election
County Commission meeting because they
felt there was a binary choice this is a
messy confusing choice people are sad
and depressed and people just want
somebody to vote for against Trump and
by the way once they get somebody to
vote for it against Trump it ain't got
like I know that the Democrats are
counting on this upsurge of enthusiasm
to vote against Trump I don't know that
that's gonna materialize those turnout
numbers do not suggest a batch of new
voters and young voters who are showing
up in massive numbers for somebody like
Bernie Sanders by the way the cash race
matters here here here is one of the
problems for the Democrats one of the
problems for the Democrats is that Trump
is blowing them out in fundraising
blowing them out here is how much cash
on hand Donald Trump had as of February
1st 2020
cash on hand a hundred and three million
dollars his nearest competitor is Bernie
Sanders who has just over 18 million
dollars cash on hand
after 2019 q for any blue a lot of that
in January by the way the top spenders
in the Democratic Party are Tom Styer
who's now spent something like 200
million dollars and Michael Bloomberg
who's spent like 280 million dollars
Bernie Sanders has spent over a hundred
million dollars Trump has been about 143
million dollars I mean the Democrats are
not going to be raising the kind of
money I think that they are going to be
that they think
going to be raising and here is the
problem right now as I say the big the
big issue here is that the moderate lane
is clogged and that became more
confusing last night not less confusing
right Buddha judge did not actually
consolidate the moderate Lane instead
Amy Klobuchar showed very strong Joe
Biden was always perceived to be sort of
the placeholder but there's nobody who's
rising up to take it people to judge
last night
he keeps campaigning as a small town
mayor who's also super savvy there's one
problem and Klobuchar is gonna nail him
on this he cannot win a state in the
Midwest he keeps saying he's gonna win
states in the Midwest he could not even
win a statewide race in his home state
of Indiana the only election he has ever
won is to mayor of South Bend Indiana
but here's people who judge pretending
that he's gonna revitalize American
politics now listen he's a very talented
guy people to judge he's very good at
modulating his tone he is Obama asked
and his ability to lie through his teeth
about his actual positions in a way that
sounds moderate that that is absolutely
true but there's one thing that people
judge does not have going for him that
Barack Obama did have going form and
that is an incredible amount of
enthusiasm Barack Obama had tons of
enthusiasm bipartisan enthusiasm really
I mean because he had done his whole red
state blue state thing and because
Barack Obama was perceived to be by many
Americans the end of racial conflict in
America at least he campaigned that way
and the early going and in cases people
who judge who is not Barack Obama to win
and to govern we need to bring new
voices to our capital we need to get
Washington starting to work more like
our best run cities and towns rather
than the other way around and I know
that when you talk this way you might
get dismissed as a naive newcomer but a
fresh outlook is what makes new
beginnings possible it is how we build a
new majority he's just channeling Obama
the problem is he ain't Obama and and
people are increasing than I recognize
this and frankly I think a lot of people
in South Carolina I think black
Americans are insulted by the idea that
people who to judge is somehow a
recapitulation of Barack Obama I don't
think that's gonna play I mean while Amy
Klobuchar gave her triumphalist third
place finished speech last night she
said we're still here you know they keep
saying leave and then we're still here I
announced my candidacy in the middle of
a Minnesota blizzard and there were a
lot of people that predicted I wouldn't
even get through that speech but not the
people of my state and not
the people of New Hampshire then they
predicted that we wouldn't make it
through the summer we did then they
predicted we wouldn't make it to the
debates and man were we at the debate in
New Hampshire what we've been is steady
we've been strong and we've never quit I
think that sounds pretty good for a
president okay there's only one problem
for her which is that again she needs to
consolidate this Lane
the Democrats are not going to
consolidate this is their biggest
biggest problem which is why there are a
lot of people who are waiting for the
deus ex machina of Michael Bloomberg
they're hoping that Michael Bloomberg
spending in the Super Tuesday states is
actually going to turn out with Michael
Bloomberg winning some sweeping
victories across the country and that by
the way includes a lot of people who are
widely perceived to be not in Michael
Bloomberg's crowd by which I mean the
pundit accuracy suggests that because
Michael Bloomberg was tough on crime in
New York City that he's widely perceived
as racist by the black community in the
United States there's not a lot of
evidence to support that again the
National polling shows that Bernt that
the Bloomberg is actually pulling ahead
of Bernie among black voters at least
with Quinnipiac poll that came out a
couple of days ago
joy Reid yesterday actually made a case
for Michael Bloomberg
she said the Democrats need a nominee
who can beat Trump and Michael Bloomberg
might be the only guy who can beat Trump
because here's the dirty little secret P
Budaj edge is not gonna be Trump Peabody
judge is not gonna win those Midwestern
states he is not Bernie Sanders has a
real problem against Donald Trump and
all the talk about how he's gonna reach
coalition's maybe it'll happen maybe it
will but that is not what the poll says
right now not in these Midwestern states
and if you think that Amy Klobuchar is
gonna be the nominee like again I think
that that'd be the smart move by the
Democrats but if you think Amy Klobuchar
is gonna be the nominee that is highly
unlikely and the reason I say it's
highly unlikely is cause she ain't
raising money her total raised in 2019
q4 was 11 million dollars 11 million
dollars
compare that to Bernie Sanders Bernie
Sanders in q4 raised thirty-five million
dollars he's blowing her out in the
fundraising and that does make a
difference when it comes time to
advertise for Super Tuesday but here was
joy Reid making the case for Michael
Bloomberg who has lots of cash and who
does have a fairly good record
particularly on crime in New York City
here is joy Reid there is a sense with
Bloomberg not that he'll break any rules
but then he'll go high and he'll go well
I think he talked about you know porn
and a cheeseburger and a putter being in
his brain
my brain - and you cannot beat Trump
unless you hit him where it hurts and
the bottom line is number one you can't
beat showbiz without showbiz and
Democrats don't understand showbiz even
though all of showbiz is on their side
Hollywood but they don't understand
showbiz and the other reality is if you
want a Democrat to win they have to know
how to fight like a Republican right
he's a Republican anyway okay also worth
noting that if anybody is going to stop
Bernie Sanders at this point is gonna be
it's gonna have to be somebody who has
some pretty heavy Union support the
reason I say that is because you could
see theoretically the guy think
Bloomberg made a mistake by waiting too
long to get in the race I think that
Bloomberg should have put a bunch of
money into Nevada right it's a small
state a lot of money in a small state
could make a big difference and in
Nevada there is a kickback against
Bernie Sanders that is happening right
now according to the Nevada independent
yesterday the keulen Airy Union warned
its members that Sanders would end their
health care if elected president that is
the biggest union in Nevada a lot of the
unions in Nevada are not happy with
Bernie Sanders because his
medicare-for-all plan basically requires
the death of all of these special union
contracts that have been negotiated in
order to achieve Cadillac health care
for their members the kuelen Airy union
which provides health insurance to
130,000 workers and their families
through a special trust fund strongly
opposes Medicare for all they've not
endorsed anybody but they are basically
unendorsed Bernie Sanders which means
that you could see somebody like Amy
Klobuchar show strong this is why it's
so bewildering that Joe Biden just
abandon Nevada it shows that he thinks
that his campaign is dead
so as I've been saying all show long
bottom line here Democrats have a
consolidation problem if collective
action problem everybody wants to be the
last person standing versus Birdie so no
one's gonna get out and that means that
bernie is likely to be the nominee
Klobuchar by the way is dropping heavy
money in Nevada well the chart
understands this she's dropping heavy
money in Nevada hoping to draw maybe a
surprise victory or surprise
second-place finish surpassing Pete
bootie judge in Nevada okay let's get
you some things that I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today so I my went out with my wife
last night my father was babysitting for
my kids I came home and he said I want
to play you this two-minute clip of Art
Tatum so for folks who don't know jazz
ken my father was professional jazz
pianist he's a terrific terrific pianist
and Art Tatum was one of his idols
growing up Oscar Peterson being the
other our Tatum was such a great pianist
that when Oscar Peterson heard him
teenager Oscar Peterson said I might
have to quit piano because nobody can
ever play like our Tatum Tatum was
nearly blind and one of the great jazz
pianists of the of the 20th century so
here is a clip of Art Tatum playing
something called Tiger Rag listen to the
cleanliness of his of his keystrokes I
mean let's listen to how clean he is on
the piano it really is unbelievable
stuff
[Music]
sophistication that he's using parities
it's pretty incredible and obviously his
style of playing is is unbelievable I
wish our piano so I could better
understand and explain you what exactly
to listen to how fast is must and there
that is that's what you're hearing in
the bass the bass part there it's
unbelievable stuff check it out it's
Tiger Rag by Art Tatum you can find it
on YouTube it's pretty spectacular stuff
this is why it's always weird to me when
people say the great American art form
is in terms of like the black art form
in America is rap know the great
American art form truly is jazz it
really is the great American musical art
form and it was largely black it was
created by black Americans and it is
unbelievable I mean Art Tatum is just
spectacular
so is Oscar Peterson I played some Oscar
Peterson on the show so if you're
looking for some jazz go check out our
Tatum or Oscar Peterson okay time for
some things that I hate alrighty so
president Trump needs to stop and what I
mean by this is stop the reason I say
stop President Trump is because the
Gallup polls right now is showing
Americans pretty happy with everything
that is going on in the country and
according to Gallup polls Trump is now
approaching 50% in terms of public
approval rating he apparently is about
to run against an octogenarian communist
so everything is going pretty well for
Trump you know what that necessitate him
stop he needs to stop being thin-skinned
and vindictive and reacting in
vindictive ways that make him look petty
and silly really he needs to stop this
I'm not talking about him firing vind
men so he fired Lieutenant Colonel Ben
Minh the other day Alexander Feynman bin
Minh was the person who I think was
wrongly maligned by some people on the
right as somehow unpatriotic for
whistleblowing about Trump's behavior on
Ukraine and then testifying about
Trump's behavior on Ukraine and I
thought that VIN means VIN means
testimony was surprisingly political I
thought that it was much more about his
disagreement with Trump on Ukraine
policy which was policy by the way I
disagreed with Trump on but I thought
that VIN mins testimony was was less
about what Trump had actually done in
terms of pushing for corruption in the
2020 election then supposedly then it
was about Vin mins
our view of Ukraine policy with that
said Trump fired Veneman and he and he
fired his twin-brother also I don't know
why I guess there's like maybe maybe
he's afraid that the twin brother would
switch places with vin minute would be
like The Parent Trap or something I
don't know what happened he those guys
were fired from the White House now it
is true they were not actually fired
from their jobs right they were just
transferred from White House duty and
that is from prag ative like if I had
somebody at this company who I thought
was reporting out on stuff that was
happening at the company to somebody
else and it wasn't criminal activity was
just them reporting stuff that they
don't like at the company that seems
like a fairly good case that they
probably should not be working at
headquarters which is what Trump did
here people going nuts over that so I'm
not talking about the Ben min thing
people on the Left are saying well how
could he get rid of Inman
that's retaliation against a
whistleblower well technically if
there's no crime he's not a
whistleblower he's just somebody who
disagrees with the policy and the
President does have a right to run his
executive branch with people who agree
with him on policy or who at least are
not going to actively undermine policy
by going and leaking it to Adam chef
okay so that that I don't have a problem
really with what he did with Ben min I
do have a problem with his intervention
with regard to Roger stone now in order
to discuss what happened with Roger
stone you need to understand that when
there are big cases in the DOJ and the
Roger stone was a big case in the DOJ
obviously cuz it had significant
ramifications for the Trump campaign
Roger stone had been charged with lying
to Congress and also lying to
investigators and trying to bully
witnesses not to testify in front of the
FBI and obstruction and all this kind of
stuff so he was sentenced the other
dated seven to nine years in prison and
a lot of people I think reasonably said
seven to nine years for what Roger stone
did is a very long sentence he's gonna
get more jail time by orders of
magnitude more jail time than Rick Gates
who had admitted to stealing money from
Paul Manafort he's gonna get orders of
magnitude more jail time then certainly
like Andrew McCabe will probably get no
jail time who also apparently lied to
investigators so I understand the case
that there is injustice in the Roger
stone case here is what I don't get so
if you have a major DOJ case it is very
rare to have a major DOJ case where the
DOJ lower downs the a das the associate
district attorneys are not actively
talking with the higher-ups in the DOJ
so they went for their sentencing
recommendation unless all the
prosecutors in that case decided to just
ignore William Bar the Attorney General
then they probably went to the
higher-ups in the goj and recommended
this seven
your sentence and bar probably signed
off on it or at the very least didn't
sound an objection to it then Trump
publicly Trump publicly says the
sentence is too much and now Trump is
publicly declaring that he had William
bar basically downgrade the sentence
recommendation from the prosecutors and
all four prosecutors on the Roger stone
case quit okay that is a bad look it is
a bad look it looks as though the
president is personal look if the
president wants to pardon Roger stone I
think that's a bad look too but he does
have the pardon power and sure he has
the the power I suppose to order his
Attorney General to do this sort of
stuff but it is a it does not look good
it looks corrupt it looks bad and mostly
it looks like William bar was twisting
in the wind I mean William bar is the
guy who left who was left out there out
front twisting in the wind and the
widespread media driven perception of
bar is that he's a political actor
anyway so unless bar comes out and he
says listen these DOJ lawyers were
basically they went rogue then when they
recommended a harsh sentence because
they don't like Trump and then I had to
come in and fix that thing then it's
hard to imagine a situation in which
lower down a das simply decided on a
high profile sentencing recommendation
without even running that up the
flagpole which is why it is a bad look
when for prosecutors abruptly withdrew
on Tuesday from the case of president
from some longtime friend Roger stone
after senior DOJ officials intervenes
recommend a more lenient sentence for
crimes he committed in a bid to protect
the president this is according to the
New York Times an extraordinary decision
overruling career lawyers the Justice
Department recommended an unspecified
term of incarceration for stone instead
of the prosecutors request of a
punishment of seven to nine years the
move coincided with Trump's declaration
on Twitter early Tuesday that the
government was treating stone too
harshly now it wouldn't been a surprise
and would have been fully precedented
for Trump to for example commute Roger
stones at sentence this actually
happened with with scooter scooter
living under the under the Bush
administration right it was felt that he
was unfairly targeted by the Department
of Justice because he was not the source
of the leaks about Joe Wilson remember
the CIA officers like Valerie Plame and
then it turned out that it was it was
richard armitage hula cleats their
identity and then apparently in the
course of the investigation scooter
libby said something that was not true
and then he ended up being sentenced and
all that bottom line is that it would
have not have been a shock the president
could take the direct power and in the
direct blame for commuting the sentence
or pardoning Roger stone if he saw fit
to but directing
Bard's who changed the sentence which it
appears what happened here and then
William bar going back on presumably
negotiations that took place between the
DOJ and the a DA's is to which sentence
to be recommended that looks really
really bad right the developments
immediately prompted questions about
whether the Justice Department was
bending to White House pressure the gulf
between the prosecutors and the DOJ
superiors burst into public view the
week before stone was to be sentenced
for trying to sabotage a congressional
investigation that had posed two threats
to the president the prosecutors were
said to be furious over the reversal of
their sentencing request the stone case
was one of the most high-profile
criminal prosecutions arising from the
nearly two-year investigation of Russian
interference in the 2016 election by
robert muller so yeah this is Trump
running for reelection maybe he feels
what's happening to Roger stone is a bad
thing okay well that's his prerogative
but you know what looks even worse you
manipulating the Justice Department
top-down in order to help your friends
right that looks even worse and Trump
should keep that in mind because if the
man wishes to win re-election then his
vindictive sense of what ought to happen
and what ought not to happen is not
going to serve him well it didn't
several moments while Ukraine debacle by
the way I know people are seeing this is
like a big victory for Trump now the big
victory is the Democrats overreached if
they not overreached and gone for center
trumpet they had a bigger problem on his
hands okay we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll be back
here tomorrow with much much more we'll
see you here either later today or
tomorrow go subscribe over it daily
wire.com use promo code GW 2020 time is
running out to get 20% off so go do that
right now because things are just gonna
get hotter and heavier as the election
cycle goes on i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel white
house key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 on the Matt
Walsh oh we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
[Music]
you